والى مستشفى الشفاء في مدينه غزه معنا من
هناك اسماعيل الغول
اسماعيل ما الذي يجري هناك في مستشفى
الشفاء نعلم جميعا ما تعرض له هذا
المستشفى ولكن ما زال يستقبل الجرحى
واليوم استقبل عددا كبير من الجرحى
وجثامين
الشهداء نعم نحن نتحدث عن مجزره جديده
ارتكبتها قوات الاحتلال بحق المواطنين في
شمال قطاع غزه وهي المجزره الثانيه بعد
حرب التجويع التي استمرت لايام طويله في
شمال القطاع 11 يوما بعد المئه وغزه لم
يدخلها المساعدات سوى ب كميات بسيطه جدا
ومحدوده جدا الى شمال القطاع حتى هذه
اللحظه تتوافد الاهالي للتعرف على الشهداء
او الاصابات التي اتت من قرب الدوار
الكويتي علما ان هذا الدوار هو المكان
الوحيد الذي تتدفق منه المساعدات من جنوب
القطاع الى شمال القطاع وفق وزاره الصحه
قرابه المئتي ضحيه ما بين شهداء وما بين
جرحى وصلوا الى داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي
بسبب القصف الاسرائيلي على حشود المواطنين
التي تجمعت قرب الدوار الكويتي لاستقبال
هذه المساعدات
ولتسليط
القطاع لكن قوات الاحتلال باغتت هذه
التجمعات بعشرات القذائف ال المدفعيه
وبالاضافه الى اطلاق النار الكثيف مما ادى
ذلك الى وقوع عشرات الاصابات وعشرات
الشهداء وصلوا الى داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي
وهذا ليس فقط المره الاولى والوحيده التي
ترتكب بها قوات الاحتلال هذه المجزره فمن
قبل قوات الاحتلال ارتكبت مجزرتي مشابهته
لهذه المجزره قرب دوار الشيخ عجلين وهي
كانت النقطه فيما قبل التي تدخل منها
المساعدات من شمال قطاع من جنوب قطاع غزه
الى شماله و فيما قبل ايضا قرب الدوار
الكويتي لكن حاله المجاعه التي دفعت
المواطنين لاستقبال هذه المساعدات بعد ان
اضطر المواطنون في شمال قطع غزه لصناعه ال
الطحين من حبوب واعلاف الحيوانات بسبب عدم
وجود اي
من البدائل التي يتغذى عليها المواطنون
لكن اليوم قوات الاحتلال ترتكب مجزره
جديده بحق الحشود والتجمعات في تلك
المنطقه حتى هذه اللحظه ننتظر الطواقم
الطبيه ان تقوم بواجبها داخل مجمع الشفاء
الطبي في ظل الضغط الكبير في داخل هذا
المجمع علما ان قوات الاحتلال من قبل دمرت
هذا المجمع وحصرته والان هذا المجمع امامه
مقات وتحديات كبيره في ظل نقص الكوادر
الطبيه ونقص الادوات الطبيه ونقص غرف
العمليات الاعداد التي الاصابات التي
توافدت الى داخل المجمع هي اصابات توصف
بالبالغين من الاصابات
كانت مبتوره الاقدام ومبتهل وباصات بليغه
الخطوره وهذا ما يشكل ضغطا وتحديا جديدا
امام الطواقم الطبيه في داخل غرف العمليات
وفي داخل قسم الاستقبال داخل مجمع الشفاء
الطبي اسماعيل الغول من مستشفى شفاء في
مدينه غزه شكرا جزيلا
لك